here's what would happen if Earth had
two moons four and a half billion years
ago we did have two moons they were both
formed when a mars-sized Proto Planet
slammed into Earth and broke apart
Earth's second moon was about three
times smaller than the current moon in
our Sky the tidal forces from both
satellites combined would make waves
literally now although these waves would
be bigger than the waves we have now
they wouldn't be devastatingly big
our smaller second moon might
inerts
orally as
as further from Earth it would
destabilize the second moon's orbit the
two satellites would Collide in slow
motion but because they'd be moving
slowly toward each other debris from the
Collision wouldn't shower back on Earth
the second moon would splatter itself
across our moon as an extra layer of
solid crust so